[Music]
we know that every function is a
relation but not every relation is a
function let's say there is a relation R
from set a to set B how do we know if
this relation R is a function or a
relation can the type of mapping from
set a to set B help us with this
information absolutely let us look at
the different types of mapping from set
a to b to know if the relation is a
function or not there are four different
types of mapping one-to-one one-to-many
many-to-one and many-to-many let's look
at the first type of mapping which is
the one-to-one mapping we have set a and
set B set a has elements a 1 and a 2 set
B has elements b1 and b2 now when can we
say that the relation from set a to set
B has a one-to-one mapping we can say
that when each element in the range is
an image of exactly one element in the
domain here our domain has elements a 1
and a 2 and our range has elements B 1
and B 2 so we see that they want is the
image of exactly one element a 1 and B 2
is the image of exactly one element a 2
if the mapping is one-to-one then the
relation is a function
do you know why this is because every
element in set a has one and only one
image in set B as we had seen in the
previous lesson this is the only
condition for a relation to be a
function now let's look at the second
type of mapping which is one to many
mapping now when can we say that the
relation from set a to set B has a
one-to-many mapping this is when an
element in the domain has more than one
image in the range a one has two images
b1 and b2 and a2 has an image b2 if the
mapping is one too many
then the relation is not a function
this is because an element in satay has
more than one image insect be for it to
be a function every element in set a
must have one and only one image in set
B let's move on to the third type of
mapping now here's the arrow diagram for
many to one mapping notice that a 1 and
a 2 both have the same image b1 can you
tell me if the relation will be a
function in this case if the mapping is
many to 1 then the relation is a
function this is because every element
in set a has one and only one image in
set three doesn't matter even if it's
the same image the relation will be a
function in this case and now we come to
the last style many-to-many here's the
arrow diagram a1 has two images b1 and
b2 and a 2 also has two images b1 and b2
will the relation be a function in this
case what do you think if the mapping is
many to many then the relation is not a
function this is because more than one
element in set a has more than one image
in set B hope the concept of mapping is
clear now we saw that when the mapping
is 1 to 1 or many to 1 the relation is a
function and when the mapping is one too
many
or many to many the relation is not a
function
[Music]